[Music]
okay everybody i am so excited today
because
i am joined by mccabe sly
aka tommy slater and fear street part 2
1978 which is
out now if you haven't watched the film
come back after you've seen it we're
going to be talking spoilers here
uh so how are you doing today mccabe i'm
so excited to talk to you
i'm doing excellent i'm super excited to
talk to you as well and talk about the
movies
yeah man dude this this movie blew my
mind how good it was i wasn't expecting
to be this good and you're a big reason
why it's so
awesome and you know what's interesting
is you being like
this new actor on the scene in the
public eye people get really jealous
it's such an awesome role for you to
land how did you even
get this part how'd it come about it was
interesting actually um
i auditioned for three different roles
in these movies
and the third one was ended up being
tommy
um i started out actually i auditioned
for
um peter and caleb who jeremy ford
played um so sam's boyfriend in 1994 and
then a character in
in 1666 then i auditioned for um
simon who fred hetchinger played
beautifully
and i'm very glad i didn't have to feel
like i could have done that or wouldn't
have done that
and then carmen brought me back for
um carmen brought me back in for for
tommy and
for matt thomas in in 1666 um
and i read for it and and literally felt
like i got a call
about a week later saying um you know
it's it's it's time to go to atlanta and
get fitted for it
um so it felt like it was a long process
in general but once it started moving it
started moving really fast
so when you say go to atlanta and get
fitted for it did they throw a sack on
your head when you went over there
they started they started to fit me for
well actually it was interesting they
did throw a sack on my head and they did
they did start molding it but they were
also fitting me for 1666 because we shot
that before
1978. oh wow okay kind of
non-sequentially because so many of the
cast from 94 shows up again in 1666
but they threw a mask on my head it was
98 degrees it was hot
lloyd my stunt double who who played
nightwing beautifully in 94 was there
with me going through it so i felt like
i had a friend for it but
it was it was hot and bothered for sure
when you were cast as tommy did you
always know it was to be the camp
nightwing killer
or did they hold that information you
for a bit you know it was interesting
the audition sides did not say that so i
did not know
um but as i as i got there obviously the
first character i was playing was in
1666 so i still had a little bit of
run-up time to feel like i was prepared
for it which was kind of nice actually
because it was there was still enough of
a surprise
and enough distance for the audition
where i felt like i was able to beat
tommy in the audition and not worry
about having to be
ominous and then you know we get to
set for 66 and we start learning about
tommy and who he turns into
interesting that that's exciting tease
in itself right there so
when we look and we first meet tommy in
this film
you know would you describe that version
of tommy as
ziggy refers to him later on as my
sister's perfect boring
virgin boyfriend is that how you saw
tommy slater the character
i'd like to think tommy's a little
cooler than that but no i think
i think that uh i think there's there's
a little bit of guilty by association
for both sides with tommy and cindy
because they really are um
just doing their best to to make a life
for themselves and and get out of
shadyside and try to find good wholesome
success somewhere else and i think that
um to a certain extent that's true he's
a good guy he's working hard he's
working at this camp he loves the kids
um and he loves cindy and i think that
that's that's kind of what he's about
see that's what's so impressive about
your performance though is you play that
so well but then
as the film goes on you have to start
playing a character who's being
possessed by a witch
was that challenging those progressing
that correctly through the movie
well i i first of all i appreciate that
it's very kind of you to say um
and then i i think i think it was it was
fun i mean the the way we shot it was
um semi out of sequence
so it wasn't quite that we had the the
actual progression
going on so it was almost like playing
two characters in the same movie
um because we would uh because we were
on different locations
for this we were at the camp and then we
were also on a sound stage for part of
the interior shots
it was it was a lot of jumping in and
out of playing
you know fully possessed you know
bloodied up nightwing killer
or throwing the mask on and then jumping
back into playing tommy who
who loves his girlfriend and and has
never had sex before um
and so i think that that made it it
wasn't even
it was it was difficult but it was a fun
difficult it made me feel uncomfortable
in the best way possible and i felt like
lee did a such a great job of helping me
drop into each of those different
scenarios whether they were possessed or
not
so when you are fully possessed now and
you're chasing after people you get to
be this awesome killer here
you're going to have a lot of jason
voorhees comparisons in this character
the camp nightwing
uh killer and i think it's really
impressive how well you do those scenes
did you study any of those famous
you know slasher killers to prepare for
those parts
yeah so it was interesting i think that
to lee's credit she did a great job of
sort of
working with me because we were already
on set for 66
and this is something that i think she
did so incredibly well she she was able
to be fully present with what she was
shooting and also be fully prepared for
the next thing that we were doing we
shot these three movies back to back to
back
and so we did a great a great thing i
think which was
literally going through all of the
references we could think of for this
character whether it was
jason voorhees or um the shining you
know
and looking at those performances and
trying to pull from those and and
keep keep it unique and keep it our own
but also really
pay homage to to what has come before us
yeah and you mentioned the shining and i
i really felt that in the moment with
the axe when you're hitting into the
door there and you open the doors it was
great moment
now i'm wondering too while watching is
how heavy is that axe i don't think
people understand like
for an actor it's not the it's a workout
you're getting right like was that
something that was like challenging a
bit that was so fun i
i actually um much to the
production insurance companies dismay
probably argued for that
to be in more scenes than not sure sure
it's got some weight to it but that
helps and also i
i i play baseball so i love swinging
stuff around and hitting stuff and
and i think that that that made it so
much fun i was jealous of
of lloyd getting to do it in 94 and
break down that door but i i was happy
to get my chance in 78.
so that's what i think people are going
to wonder too when you see something
like this so
those scenes we see with the sack on the
head did you actually have to wear the
sack during filming at all or is it all
the stunt double
yeah so it's a little bit of mix of both
and and it's it's
really i think a credit to lloyd how
seamless he makes it looks
because you know i can't tell the
difference my friends can't tell a
different
cast can't tell the difference um and i
think that that that's what makes it so
fun is is that
you know it's one character the whole
time and i think he did a great job but
it's it's me in there sometimes and him
and they're the others and we're both
we were both struggling through the
humidity and the heat together in that
thing
is something else so is there a sick
thrill you get to watching yourself
chopping people's heads off
you know what they're there is and i i i
need to preface that by saying that
um i know it's fake i'm not actually
getting up i'm feeling like i'm killing
people
um but yeah there's definitely you know
it's fun it's it's it's one of those
things where it's it's playing pretend
it's
it's like when you were a kid and you
had got to run around and imagine things
and i think that
i wasn't imagining those things again
no it's definitely fun especially when
you get to watch it with the person you
killed
like you're just next to them and you
know they're alive you're like hey
wasn't that fun when your head fell off
well yeah
we were cool right and you know it was a
lot of fun
did you have a favorite kill or just
favorite moment in the whole film you
could pick even that you just that
sticks with you the most
man i think like i gotta say what
i mean killing killing
it's tough one it's a tough one there
are so many i mean i like
there's there's a moment where i where i
walk into the arts and craft cabin
and i think i just love the way it's
it's come together at the end
um where where they turn they have the
the lights go out and they turn on the
lighter and then i'm there and i think
that's just a cool moment
obviously cutting off gary's head is is
like
one of my favorite things i've ever
that's my favorite kill oh my god
it's the best moment it was it was just
such a fun day there were so many there
were so many uh
we had one we had one shot to get that
right in the sense because if
we were using the real axe and it was a
dummy so if i
missed you could see the cut on like the
fake neck or the fake head
so we had to get it right there and and
i think luckily we got it good enough to
where it it played but it that was so
much fun and then the body coming down
and
like falling oh my god it's just it's
just too good it's just so the baseball
playing all comes full circle to
actually use those skills of swinging
right there it was funny there was
another shot where like
lee wanted me to hit a mark on the
ground and get the axe stuck
and she wanted me to get it right
between the boards so it wouldn't mess
the wood up
and i was being fake confident i said i
could do it and then i did it and i got
so surprised that i like
like looked and said hey i did it and
she's like stay in the scene
but yeah no the baseball definitely came
into play it was fun it was a lot
that's awesome um so switching gears a
little bit i mean
i think a lot of people are excited
about this one too because you had this
big movie premiere i think you guys have
a couple
um what is that like for you being on a
red carpet with names like gillian
jacobs and sadie stink and working with
sadie singularity like how has that been
for you it's been it's been it's
it's actually been pretty surreal just
because i think that uh
the way i met gillian was was funny we
went to uh in the middle of filming we
had a short break for the stranger
things i think it was season four
premiere
we went all went to the the premiere of
it and got to
to sit in and i ended up sitting next to
gilly and i had never met her before and
so we just hung out and got to know each
other then
working with sadie i think we we
actually shot scenes together
was like a master class in in how far i
feel like i have to go as an actor and a
performer i mean she's
phenomenal and and so up for anything i
think one of the
best parts about working with her was
you know how
ready she was to be like physical i mean
the scenes we have are not exactly like
hey how are you nice to see you
um you know i'm throwing her into a wall
trying to choke me with the bag and it's
like
right to feel like i've got um
she's matching my energy with that it
was awesome and to feel like i had to up
my energy to match hers was even better
it you know it brought me back to
feeling like i was playing sports again
and trying to you know match up with
somebody who was just as good
definitely better than i was oh that
that's awesome to hear and you know
sadie sang has this huge following so
that her fans are gonna be awesome to
hear that too
um so are you then prepared mentally for
the attention you're about to get with
the success this trilogy is already
having but
the reaction how people are gonna watch
this film and you get to be the killer
here which is a huge
huge thing like so are you ready for
that attention
i i don't think it's something that i
can prepare for i think if i tried to i
would either overestimate or
underestimate it and it just wouldn't
work i'm trying to take it one
one day at a time i think one of the
benefits and sort of cheat codes i have
is my mom was an actress at one point
and she was on a show called l.a law in
the 90s which was a very popular law
show and
experienced some level of fame back pre
sort of social media and so she's been a
real help in terms of sort of
knowing what to expect and having some
good ideas about how to handle it
that's awesome so you know coming from
that being around it i guess in your
family was there
when was the moment for you when you
knew you wanted to do this man i mean
she was really great about never pushing
it on me i didn't really
even start acting until i was in high
school and
because i played a spring sport our
school needed more guys to audition for
the fall musical which happened to be
west side story my senior year
and so i i did that musical i fell in
love with it immediately i got a lead
role
for for whatever reason our theater
director thought i could
do it um but that was the first time i
really acted at all and
i just loved being on stage and feeling
like you know i knew there was a crowd
but i couldn't see any faces
and so it felt nice to feel like i was
kind of just up there with my cast mates
and
it was it was really just a phenomenal
experience and my
current manager happened to be in one of
the audiences and and so
signed me out of there and from there we
went and and it's been
you know a blessing and a dream ever
since
that's amazing do you have any actors or
actresses you currently look up to
oh man uh i think my top one is is
jonathan majors
and i i was lucky enough to spend three
years working with him and and
getting to know him and that's that's my
big brother and he's
someone i look up to in in in
all shapes and side in all forms really
i mean he's he's the man
so i think that's that's the guy i look
up to at the moment
that's a great answer um and look you've
been giving me great answers this whole
interview it's been so fun to talk to
you
before i let you go mccabe because
people came with an asses can you
give us a little tease about 19 i mean
60 1666 the third film coming up because
we do see you
in the little preview they give us at
the end of two so anything you can kind
of
give us a little what we might expect
yeah you can expect me to instead of
having blood on my face i have dirt on
my face i have
i have blacked out teeth i think the one
thing that i love about these
these movies is um they each have a sort
of a different theme so 94 is sort of
like a screen vibe
78 brings you back to the slasher films
66 is the scariest one
66 really gets under your skin into your
head and makes you
scared to walk around your house at
night like it's it's mentally
terrifying so i think people are going
to really love it and then it jumps back
to 94 at the end
and and we get to have some fun at the
end of it but it really gets you at the
beginning
oh i i can't wait so you heard it from
him everybody
check out mccabe as tommy slater if you
haven't for some reason watch part two
it's out now watch it now and then this
friday
he'll be back in part three uh thank you
so much for joining me mccabe and i hope
to talk to you in the future one day
thank you it's nice to meet you man